yeah i read something where it was like
it was years later because you know
you know your mom was sick she had an
aneurysm or something and and you're
you're yeah your dad was you guys were
talking outside and this was like two
thousand
three and he and he was that was
actually in 1998 my mom died in 2003
um and and she died after
having survived a brain aneurysm
five years prior and it was just sort of
like one of these things where
you know i understood that she like
cooked some three-course
meal you know like with normal normal
and then like the next morning
i kind of got up and and and whatever
happened like she had just had a blood
vessel in her brain just
popping there was no way to see it
coming or anything and
uh it was just a super you know get into
the hot you know
and most people don't survive these uh
subarachnoid brain hemorrhages um
you know and mom did survive it but
what was left really uh
physically and mentally disabled and um
and whatever
in the you know she had brain surgery
all this and the family
came from adult dad i think had flew
over from england and
and my sister and i were in albuquerque
new mexico we all met in florida
and it was just this kind of crisis
management situation
and um and we left at the hospital just
for a meal
and it was it was uh at this this this
restaurant
and you know this crazy circumstances
where moms
you know got this brain thing
and uh and dad chose that time to say
hey son i feel i've done a disservice to
you
um by not supporting you in this career
path that you've
clearly committed yourself to and he
said you know
my dad i didn't choose what my dad
wanted he had a similar conversation
with him you know and son you didn't
you know you're not doing what i would
have chosen for you but given that
you're committed to it
i i you know i just want you to be the
best at it you know what i pledge to
support you and i put a lot of wind in
myself
did you were you emotional um i mean it
was it was a heavy
heavy uh situation i mean that was like
the least of what was going on at the
time yeah
it meant a lot you know um it was almost
like all right you know i
i almost didn't think that that would
really change a whole lot
i was like okay well you know i'm kind
of a loser at that point i had not
made any money i had not uh
really accomplished anything i'd had uh
you know
photos and a couple of skateboard
magazines and the photos were not of me
skateboarding
you know like i just did not have my act
together and uh so it's
it's a big credit to my dad that he
you know didn't jump on the bandwagon
after i had some success
you know like i i i really love to say
that
i don't feel uh having a
great relationship with my father is
because i'm successful
but rather i think that you know i've
been able to achieve
some success because i have a great
relationship with my father and that's a
a really just a really major distinction
that that does make me feel emotional